I hear he wants to do a horror movie as
his last movie or something I did I take
take nothing you ever hear the oh here's
when you know the next what the next
Tarantino movie is going to be when he's
on set shooting it because his entire
career
oh here's what I'm gonna do next here's
what I want to do next here's what I
think I should do here's what we're
gonna do you know whatever we're gonna
do the Vega Brothers we're gonna do kill
the volume three we're gonna do the
prequel doing glorious bastards these
are all things that he's talked about at
length and none of them have happened so
here's what I believe will happen he
when we were shooting bastards said he's
going to retire from filmmaking when
he's 60. he's going to make 10 movies
and that's that and I was like come on
you're not gonna you're gonna walk away
and this was the phrase you use he said
I'm going to become a man of letters
what is that what does that even mean so
I'm going to be a writer say I'm a
writer I was like oh okay so the
novelization of Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood that he put out a few years
ago which I don't know if you haven't
read it it's [ __ ] great
um
he's going to do that I think for either
all of his films or he's going to start
writing the book versions of the movies
that he never had the time
to actually make so I believe we'll get
the Vega Brothers book we'll get in
glorious bastards the prequel book
Kill Bill vol 3 the book that's my
feeling